okay so as a woman as a wife Ali what
does it mean to be submissive so the
word submissive has a negative
connotation on it so what would probably
be more digestible for women's ears
would be willful cooperation if your man
has a good program and it's trusted
proven and Justified Authority in that
relationship Authority with
responsibility because he's responsible
for the outcomes of the relationship if
if you have that you're naturally going
to follow and that's the thing about it
is some women talk about you know high
value man high value man there's a lot
of different components to masculinity I
can say for certain that I don't worry
about my physical safety in the presence
of my husband at all he's a strong dude
I met that guy he shook my hand real
strong he's a trade fighter and he's
also trained with weapons so I don't I
don't have to worry about that so of
course I'm like let me let me get what
this program this program is awesome I'd
like the subscription to last for the
rest of my life and that's what women
don't want to hear but well because they
haven't had experience with it because
they can't keep a man but uh the thing
about submission itself is that it has a
really convoluted understanding your
your man that you quote-unquote submit
to willful cooperation you will fully
cooperate with him he has to have
something bigger than himself that is
the goal and some people break it down
to religion like that's fabulous but I
know for my my relationship my husband
is not a Believer but he believes in the
greater good of humanity and Society so
he's always trying to do good in the
world so I don't have to worry about him
going mad with power and that's also a
weird narrative that women come up with
they're like well what's gonna happen if
you give a Manpower well like they gave
us Wi-Fi and air conditioning I think
they're doing great with power and
because they pick the wrong men to give
power to so they put that on all men so
it's like again they're putting your
poor choices on all of us just because
you can't find a man to submit to
doesn't mean we can't so right and it's
argumentative women that they struggle
with submission because women that are
coming from two parent houses
well-rounded I live in the midwest I
know a lot of women that understand that
when there is trusted and proven and
Justified Authority they're like yes I
would like your help I'm going to go
with the flow on this one but women just
don't want to be honest that like you're
not fun to be around people are tired of
argue with you people don't want to
people are not fighting over your
invitation at the party they would
rather you didn't go well and a lot of
like more feminine girls we prefer it
like I hate making decisions like
honestly like I hire a couple people now
and like I hate it it's hor it's so
against my personality if I could just
have someone like do that part of the
job for me I would prefer it like it is
so much easier as a girl like working
for someone than it is like having like
managing all these people so she used
instead of the word submissive willful
cooperation yes okay I'm so confused by
that term okay so yeah I mean I would
figure you're very successful yes yes so
it would be hard to imagine applying
that work ethic but in a relationship
I'm still confused do you think you can
explain no break it down so so do you
not understand the wolf of cooperation
or the submission willful cooperation
um like Croatian you know so okay okay
so simple it so basically it's giving
your man Authority which is not
something that's often done in society
but give me an example okay so you're
getting dressed and your dress is a
little bit provocative maybe you're a
little bit ignorant on it he says you
know honey you're showing a little bit
much I don't know if you're aware do you
mind changing like would you argue with
him or would you put on a different
dress if I think the dress looks hot I
would wear it yeah well that's that's
making it about you and how your
relationship that's yeah the opposite of
willful cooperation okay so yeah that's
not me yeah okay so let's stay there for
a second because
um I've dated some girls that look good
in dresses and maybe they looked a
little too good and I was like you know
the whole honey my does this make my
butt look good or hell yeah whatever
whatever but you're saying as a man hey
babe you know
a little much I don't feel comfortable
with this would you mind changing you
would change I would absolutely change
and it's not just about the impression
that I would have out there on the world
it's protection because I could get the
wrong kind of attention from an unhinged
man and what would happen if you get
some attention from like a man from from
which man that I don't want the
attention from I'm being sexualized by a
stranger I don't want that but what do
you mean by attention somebody looking
at you that like meant men are gonna
look they always look so what let them
look I don't want to be sexualized by
someone that's not my husband okay so
why do you post stuff online
I'm sure some guys watch their stuff go
through my Instagram pretty it's pretty
kosher like I mean okay there's some
weirdos out there I'm sure man when
you're with a guy you represent him so I
I would never want to wear something
that's like embarrassing to a dude no I
agree with that I never like I would not
go I would never wear something
inappropriate for a situation but if a
guy like I usually tell my boyfriend to
choose my outfits just because he has
good style like he has good taste so
like he would never I'm personally not
like a vulgar person so what I'm saying
is like if he deemed it inappropriate
like like submitting is trusting his
judgment and so I trust yeah if
submitting is trusting a guy's judgment
but but then I agree but you wouldn't in
that situation because you said no I
would still wear what I want like I felt
that my outfit is appropriate for the
occasion right but that's that's what
submitting is saying even though I think
it's appropriate I'm gonna trust my man
to make that decision but is that a
slippery slope right there meaning when
does
the the submission part
start meaning
we've been dating for three months six
months does it start when you're
official does it start when you're
married meaning if you've only been with
a guy for a couple months and he's like
hey would you mind changing I kind of
get Coco's perspective like I don't know
you like that buddy are you doing but if
this is America this is your husband
according to Ali go ahead and change
baby are you are you dating with
intention are you dating just just to
date is the question because if Define
the difference so if you're dating with
like the expressed intention on both
parties to get married okay like you
have to show him what like what you're
gonna do in the marriage okay so like
some people just date to have fun and
date around like I can understand not
submitting to a guy if you're just
dating to date but if you want to get
married like you have to show that guy
what he's gonna get when he marries you
Coco your response no I had a question
for her so I feel like you're a very
family oriented person right we have a
big family what would happen let's say
you get married to a guy and five years
into the marriage he gets into a huge
fight with one of your family members
and he's like I never want to go to your
house again what would you do
wow that's a really good question thank
you
um I wouldn't choose a guy that would
get between me and my family that's not
my question let's say maybe maybe there
was an event maybe people I don't know
if you guys are drinking or not you know
maybe there was a party Something's
Gonna something happens okay
um if I if he was my husband I would
trust his judgment so you would
you would not speak to your family ever
again because of your husband well you
said one family member okay maybe okay
one we can lose there's there's like
yeah like I would like with your dad I
see you're very close to your dad if
your dad gets into a fight with your
husband what would you do if my dad got
into a fight with my husband
um maybe because you were very
submissive and I'm not I don't know
what's your family situation I don't
want to like well I I let my dad vet the
guys that I date actually but so I agree
with that too but things can happen down
the line like five years in maybe maybe
my dad doesn't drink either so it's a
little different okay this is a
hypothetical but it like it is you said
it's what I think that's more of an
exception argument well what if whatever
but but it's not an if because
relationships and family are going to
fight at the end of the day like I would
if it was my husband I would trust my
husband over my family especially if
that's someone I have a child with okay
like that's that's your husband that's
who you picked
um I mean I feel differently I do
everything I would do everything in my
power to like make that work out
um what are your thoughts
uh obviously whatever the situation
would be I would try to use my own
judgment first and I would try to listen
to both sides but I see a lot in luckily
I don't have this in my family but I
hear a lot of people have issues like oh
I hate my mother-in-law or I can't stand